bu internette ses var yani dijital Ee
teknolojiye Eser seçtim konuşma başlığı
Öncesinde çok kısa biraz daha artık
yanından bahsetmek istiyorum ki sunduğum
programlar yardımcısı kendimize neden bu
konularla ilgilendiğini den ve neler
yaptığımı birleşmiş milletleri 13 yıldır
yaklaşık düzenlediği internet yönetişim
formunun 5 yıldır da ufak dost aylarının
organizatörü kolaylaştırıcısı konuşmacı
olarak Farklı panellerde çalıştaylarda
yer aldım Aynı zamanda 5 yıldır bu sene
altı yılımız olacak Türkiye internet
gençlik internet iletişim formunu
koordine ediyorum yani teknoloji ve
internet benim ilk kullanmaya
başladığımdan beri happy
bu çeken ve potansiyeline inanılmaz
inandığım buluşlardan Belki onun için
geçerlidir yeni bu olduğunu yalnız
olduğunu hiç zannetmiyorum ve hepimizin
bildiği gibi inanılmaz bir şurada
değişiyor gelişiyor evrimleştirme bizim
kullanım alışkanlıklarınız aynı şekilde
Aynı hızla değişiyor gelişiyor ve
evrimleşiyor özellikle son birkaç aydır
git Global olarak yaşadığımız bu kendimi
sürecinde ciddi zaten hızlı olan
dijitalleşme artık akıl almaz bir kıza
ulaştı en basitinden şu anda üzerinden
bu günleri düzenlediğimiz Zoom video
konferans uygulaması Hadi öncesi 10
milyon kişi tarafından kullanılırken
halde mi sonrası iki üç ayda 200 milyon
kullanıcıya ulaştı bu birçok farklı
teknolojik dijital uygulama için
internet bazlı uygulama için geçerli Ama
bu akıcı rakam bulamaz halkımızın ne
kadar hızlı değişebileceğini bunun
nelere etki edebileceğine dair bize kısa
bir fikir
çok farklı rakamlar vermek istiyorum
dünyadan ve Türkiye'den Çünkü neden
internete ses ver diyorum neden
teknoloji neden dijital ses ver diyorum
Çünkü bizim sesimizi Abi özellikle son
zamanlarda sesi zaten ses veren
iletişimi demokrasisine eden yer arşı
sini Geleneksel medya tüketim diğer
enerjisini bozan bir yer işimizi kökten
değiştiren bu teknolojinin özellikle
ülkemizde Türkiye'de çok 22
farklılaşmayı Türkiye'nin dünyanın 22 en
büyük macunu ekonomisi üzerinde yapılmış
iki senelik bir araştırma var 2018'e
yılında yapılmış bu 22 büyük ekonomi
arasında Türkiye'de var ve bana
şaşırtıcı gelen bir şekilde Türkiye tüm
bu ülkelerden 21 diğer büyük ekonomisi
sahibi ülkelerden bizde 5 daha fazla
dijital Medya kullanıyor ve tüketiyor
oyun konsolları dışında en çok mobil
masaüstü eve benzeri cihazlar Türkçe
iyi bakın tekrarlıyorum dünyadaki 22 en
büyük ekonomi arasında Türkiye çoğu
alanda dizel meyve tüketiminde hem
ekipman anlamında hem de medyanın
kendisini tüketmek anlamında bir yerden
hep bir adım önde gidiyor peki bu kadar
Severek isteyerek şirk ettiğimiz devesi
bir şekilde tükettiğimiz dijital
teknolojiler hakkında internet hakkında
nasıl yönetildiği ve hayatımızı nasıl
etkilediği hakkında yeterince
düşünüyoruz Çünkü bunları düşünmek
bunların üstünde durmamak şu anda hemen
etkisini Göremeyeceğiz ama kısa ve orta
ve uzun vadede hayatımızın aklınıza
gelebilecek her yönünü kökten
etkileyecek sonuçlara yol açıyor ister
öyle ister Özel Hayat olsun ekonomik
durumumuz olsun politik durumları olsun
sosyal hayatımız olsun Ve tabii ki iş
hayatımız olsun ve öğrenme yaptı
olabilir bilerek artan bir hızla bu
teknolojilerden yararlandığımız için hem
nasıl tükettiğimiz hem
bu teknolojilerin kimler tarafından
nasıl üretildiğini konuşmak gerektiğini
düşünüyorum çoğunuzun bildiği gibi
dünyanın en fazla kâr eden en büyük
teknoloji şirketlerinin çok büyük bir
çoğunluğunu Amerika menşeli Amerika'da
kurulmuş çok mutlu olsalar bile
merkezleri hep ortaları Amerika'da olan
şirketler Amerika'da olmasının ötesinde
çalışanların oranlarına baktığımızda
demografik değerlerine baktığımızda
cinsiyet anlamında ırk anlamında yaş
anlamında farklı kıstaslar aldığımızda
teknolojiyi yaratanlar ve enerji ile
ilgili ararlar verenler karar merciinde
ki insanların ağırlıklı olarak beyaz ırk
mensubu biyolojik olarak erkek ve kuzey
yarımküre yani Kuzey yarım söylediğinde
işte Amerika Kanada ve Avrupa
ülkelerinden olduğunu görüyoruz Bu yani
Amerika için de geçerli ve bu
bahsettiğim şirketler hangi
Bu arada Örnek vermek gerekirse durumdan
tutun Apple A6 bathing Google'ye
bildiğimizi ürünlerinde şirketine
bebeğin şirketi olan altı bathing Amazon
vesaire ve diğerleri Facebook bunların
kremleri ve karar verecek mercilerinde
ve teknolojinin üretildiği tasarlandığı
Bizim her kullandığımızda okumadan geçip
Tamam kabul ediyorum dediğimiz gizlilik
şartlarından tutun kullanım politikaları
ve komünite kuralları Yani bizim nerede
Niye ne kadar paylaşabileceğimiz e karar
veren neyin uygun değil uygun olmadığına
karar veren Belki şu anda Bu şirketler
devletlerden Dayı güçlü duruyorlar bizim
sesimizi nasıl kullanacağımızı kendimizi
cinlere hangi platformlarda nasıl
yansıtır sunabileceğimiz ile alakalı bu
Hem bireysel fazla geçerli hem de
kitlesel anlamda geçerli Google hemşire
Yazdığınız zaman ingilizce-türkçe önemli
değil ve görsel ve tıkladığım zaman
genelde Google size
bu görselleri veriyor hemşire ve kadın
mühendis yazıp yazıp aradığınız zaman
veya doktor yazıp aradığım zaman
görsellerde erkek imajları çıkıyor bilim
ne kadar önemli olduğu düşüncelerimizi
kültürümüzü sosyal yaşamımızı
şekillendirdiği zaten bilinen bir gerçek
arama motoru gibi sürekli hepimizin hem
iş için hem özel etsin her şeyde
kullandığımız vee Belki geri geldiğinde
en yakın arkadaşımıza bile Danış
almadığımız şeyleri sorduğumuz arama
motorlarının bize verdiği sonuçlar ve
eğlendirip karşımıza çıkardı bilgiler
görseller ve Dijital Medya Bu
bahsettiğim sınırlı grup tarafından
karar veriliyor algoritmalar kodlar ve
kullanım politikaları toplulukla beyaz
erkekler tarafından yazılıyor yani
burada bahsetmek istediğim şey belli bir
kötü niyet bir Komplo Teorisi vesaire
gibi bir şey yok Ne olarak bende Mesela
şu an bir teknoloji şirketinde Yoldayken
bu içinden nedir bu yarı Türk yarı
Amerikalı genç Heteroseksüel Bir kadın
bu perspektiften bakabileceğim ama karar
verilen karar verilen odalarda ve
kullandığınız çektiğimiz teknoloji
üretildiği odalarda böyle bir temsil
olmadığında bu doğal olarak üretilen
ürünler ve bunların nasıl kullanılacağı
da çok kısıtlı bir kitlenin doğruları
yanlışları ve bakış açıları tarafından
şekilde şekillendirilmiş oluyor Bununla
ilgili Amerika ve Global olarak
araştırmalar yapan birçok bağımsız
çarpıcı bitmeyen kuruluş var Bunlardan
biri de asendy Vakfı w2007v 2015
arasında yaptıkları araştırmaları göre
asyalıların Emine ister O tipi vardır
teknoloji şirketinde gelen asyalar
çalışıyor çünkü kafaları çalışıyorum
vesaire gibi biraz ülke biraz fazla
genelleyici yaklaşımlar vardır ama
rakamlar bunu göstermiyo rasyonlarına
bu en büyük 8 teknoloji şirketinde işe
alınma oranları incelenmiş en yüksek
Asyalı işe alınıyor ama terfi oranları
en düşük yine Asyalılar da yani kapıdan
girmek kolay yüklenmek zor niye
dönüyoruz yine karar verecek mercileri
yani karar verdim Pepee noktalara
çıkıldıkça temsil bir bu tarz şeyler
yüzünden azalıyor cinsiyetten
bahsetmişken özellikle son yıllarda
Birçok araştırma ve farkındalık
kampanyası ve politika değişiklikleri
yapılıyor ve bu gelişmeleri izlemek çok
güzel ama sandığım benim en azından bu
rakamlara bakmadan önce sandığımın
aksine cinsiyetten ziyade ırk daha
belirleyici faktör olarak belirlenmiş
teknoloji şirketlerini başvururken işe
alınırken terfi alırken ve genel olarak
aldığımız maaş oranı ile alakalı
eşitsizlikler var yani belki düşünmemiz
gereken şimdi Ülke dendiğinde ve
Amerika'dan bahsedildiğinde Tabii ki
Amerika
en kozmopolit ve çok kültürlü çok uluslu
bir ülke Ama bunu sadece biraz bakış
açımızı genişletme mizi rica ediyorum
Sadece Afrika Amerikalılar Asyalılar ya
da işte Silikon vadisi'nde ülke göre
işçi alınıyorsa Birileri bizi ne
ilgilendirir gibi bir noktadan bakmamız
gerektiğini istiyorum çünkü azınlık
dediğimiz zaman sonra Amerikalı yaşayan
milyonlarca Türk var bunların bazıları
Evet teknoloji sektöründe çalışıyor ve
onlarda azınlık sarılıyorlar Çünkü az
önce bahsettiğim O bir gruba dahil
değiller be yazık Bu veya bu ama kuzey
yarımküre ve erkek olmaya yani
teknolojinin nasıl şekillendirdiğini
nasıl geliştireceği nasıl Evlenince
nasıl kullanılacağını karar vermenin
öneminin farkına varıp diğer bu
temsiliyeti artırmak istediğinizde de
karşılaştığımız Çok mecbur yerler var
Dediğim gibi iş almakla akıllı terfi
almak ve alakalı ve kazanacağınız paraya
kadar teknik roller de
bir şeye bakmak yeterli değil bu
rakamlarda Mesela Facebook her sene
Açıklıyor ne kadar tamponun olduğu
tarçını kadar şeffaf olduğu tartışılır
Ama her sene şeyi Açıklıyor İşte bu
kadar kişi işe aldık bu kadar kadın bu
kadar erkek bu kadar azınlık bu kadar
hispanik Bu kadarı Afrikalı Amerikalı
siyahi ve benzeri ama Bu rakamlar bazen
aldatıcı olabiliyor Çünkü bu kadar büyük
on binlerce insanın çalıştığı
şirketlerde işe alınmak Demek az önce
bahsettiğim karar verdim erce de
olduğunuz anlamına gelmiyor işe alınmak
demek etkin olabileceğiniz bir rolde
yeterince iyi çalışırsanız o terfi
alacağınız anlamına gelmiyor o yüzden
bakmamız gereken rakamlar ve temsiliyet
karar verici mercilerde ne kadar azınlık
ve çeşitlilik ve hem cinsiyet anlamında
hem etnik köken anlamında dil din ırk
cinsel yönelim hepsi anlamında bir
çeşitlilik var mı yok mu diye
Bu anlamda bir teknik roller deniyor bu
teknik pozisyonlar yani Bu ürünlerin
üretildiği kodların yazıldığı Odalar
birincisi İkincisi de see you level
dediğimiz ediyor O yüzden işe alınma
şeylere bakmamız yeterli değil bu ne
gibi görünmez bariyer vardır Bunlar
ilerleyen süreçlerde hayatımızı nasıl
etkiliyor tekrar tekrar şimdi Çünkü
internet bize bu sesi veriyor ancak
kimin nasıl ürettiğini ve nasıl
kullanmanızı dikti ettirdiğini sorgulama
aldığımız sürece ve tüketiciden sadece
tüketici olmaktan üretici olmaya geçişi
geçişe daha fazla önem değer vermeye
başladığımız sürece geçici olmaya da
tümüyle başkalarının bize dayattığı
kurallarla hayatınızı yaşayın
şekillendirmeye mahkumuz gibi görünüyor
ve bu konuyu seçmemin Öncelikle sebebi
buydu Çünkü dediğim gibi internetin
bu teknolojilerin dönüştürücü gücüne ve
potansiyeline gerçekten yürekten inanan
ve bununla ilgili farklı çalışmalar
yapan bir insanın ama günün sonunda
bunlardan bahsetmek yeterli değil bazı
görünür ve görünmez bariyerlere
odaklanmamız ve aynı zamanda kullanışlı
ve tüketicisi olduğumuz ürünlerin kimler
tarafından nasıl üretildiğini ve nasıl
kurallar konulduğunu takip etmeniz
gereken kesinlikle inanıyorum Bununla
ilgili aktiviteler de buna STK lar var
hem Global düzeyde hem Türkiye'de
bulunan dijital kapasite deneme dijital
kapasitenin alanınız ne olursa olsun
Eğer bu dinleyen bir öğrenciyseniz ister
bilgisayar mühendisliği okuyor olun
ister hukuk okuyor olun ister sosyoloji
okuyorum Aklımızdan Evidea fazla bir
çalışan sınıf Teknoloji şekilde
çalışması gerek yok bunun için yani ya
da değil mi öğrenciyseniz teknoloji ile
ilgili bir bölüm okuyor olması gerekiyor
bu çağımızın doğası giderek böyle olacak
her şey daha interdisipliner olmaya
başladı O yüzden mesela ilkokul
öğrencisinin teknolojiden En azından
belli bölge kadar anlaması gerekiyor
çünkü giderek daha fazla bu ve
teknolojik içiçe geçmeye başladı bu
sadece herhangi bir örnek bu
interdisipliner likte aynı zamanda bu
temsiliyeti Kahveci mercilerde teknoloji
şirketlerindeki temsilci temsiliyeti de
mutlaka gün denizcilerimiz de tutmamız
gerektiğine inanıyorum çünkü bize ses
veren internetin geleceği tam olarak
buna bağlı ve gün üslubunda tüketicisi
olduğumuz şeyin üretici olmasında
üreticisi olmanız da mümkün sadece bir
belli bir farkındalık ve bu Tıpkı birden
fazla faktörü göz önünde bulundurarak
bak almamız gereken kararlar ve ilgi
alanları olduğunu düşünüyorum internet
bu dijital Eser teknoloji ses var derken
tekrar benim üretim ve tüketim
alışkanlıklarımızı gözden geçirmemiz kim
Hangi odalarda ne kadar sensin ediliyor
bunu her zaman aklımızda bulundurmamız
gerekiyor ve son olarak yine cinsiyetle
alakalı bir iki beri paylaşarak bitirmek
istiyorum 2019'da Birleşmiş Milletler'in
ilk olur diye bir girişimi var Rober
düzeyde Onların yaptığı araştırmada
dünyadaki en bilgisayar kullanımının
yüzde 53'ü erkek bilgisayar kullanan Tüm
insanlar arasında yüzde üç erkek yüzü 36
yalnızca kadında internet kullanımında
kullanımında ise yüzde yetmiş üç erkek
yüzde 57 adında burada yüzdebirlik fark
bile bizim için çok önemli O yüzden
bahsettiğim teknoloji üretme noktası bu
odalara girme noktasının ötesinde
Kullanıcı olarak da eşitliği sağlamamız
gerekiyor dil din ırk
İyi afiyet ve Benzer şeyleri ayırt
etmeden Çünkü internet yaşamdır ve
internet herkes ve